Donald Trump is a good
man
H wow I know what you would
say that's
correct you're you're were right too it
obvious I know why you said it to you
would say to why would I say you're a
lying
do I obviously am accepting the
anthropological fact that none is good
but God I'm obviously accepting the
Fallen both accept that so we're talking
relative to presidents and politicians I
think actually relative to our degraded
state of politicians and and leaders I
think he's in the upper 50% in terms of
his virtue I think he raised basically
good kids he got divorced he's had all
sorts of problems he I think he's run a
business actually pretty honestly he
seems to you know it's funny that when
the one thing about these indictments is
they point out that he's never really
done anything all that bad yes